[Music]
can you call dwayne johnson little
brother and survive vin diesel thinks he
can this is the complete timeline of the
explosive feud between hollywood's
biggest and baldest action stars
the year is 2011 a new show called game
of thrones is airing on hbo adele's
rolling in the deep is on the top of the
charts and a street racing franchise
called fast and furious is coming off
its most recent successful installment
the 2009 film fast and furious but
that's nothing compared to the fifth
film that's about to premiere aptly
titled fast five which helps propel the
series to become one of the most
successful franchises in history there
are many reasons for the film's stunning
success but one obvious reason is the
addition of former wwe superstar dwayne
the rock johnson to the cast fast 5
kicks off a golden age for the franchise
feeding into the successes of fast and
furious 6 and furious 7. all three films
feature the rock's luke hobbs character
and his on-screen dynamic with diesel
paul walker and the rest of the cast is
compelling tragedy struck the series in
the form of walker's death in 2013 but
his friends and co-stars rallied behind
his legacy and pushed forward the future
of the franchise still looked a bit
uncertain but an eighth core film the
fate of the furious was announced and
entered production
on august 8th 2016 one week before
production wrapped for the fate of the
furious johnson took to instagram and
made a post that he then quickly deleted
in it he praised many members of the
film's cast and crew while also calling
out a few unnamed people with
particularly colorful language after
praising all the women he starred with
johnson turned his attention to his male
co-stars saying that some conduct
themselves as stand-up men and true
professionals while others don't the
ones that don't are too chicken to do
anything about it anyway candy asses he
added that when you watch this movie
next april and it seems like i'm not
acting in some of these scenes and my
blood is legit boiling you're right a
tmz report published shortly after the
post was made claimed that the man
johnson was targeting with his pro
wrestling style insult was none other
than diesel himself and that the two
actors had major tension on set
throughout the production process on
august 10th johnson made another
instagram post that seemingly swept his
previous frustrations under the rug in
it he thanked the whole cast and crew
for their hard work and said that like
with any team that's a family there's
gonna be conflict family is gonna have
differences of opinion and fundamental
core beliefs i was raised on healthy
conflict and welcome it and like any
family we get better from it things at
least for the moment seem to have calmed
back down we're family
we got a problem we deal with it
together
despite johnson's apparent attempt to
squash the beef the story he'd made
public refused to die down diesel shared
a vague response to instagram on august
10th promising the public that he would
quote tell you everything soon co-star
michelle rodriguez then confirmed in an
interview with people that there had
been tension between the two but that
she believed they cared about each other
and would work it out you never turn
your back on family and i want to thank
you all
for never turning your back on me
on august 19th johnson made another
instagram post after filming had
officially wrapped in which he thanked
many of his co-stars in the film by name
notably excluding diesel though the
insult was by omission it seemed clear
that whatever had gone on between the
two actors was still unresolved even if
they'd put their differences aside for
the sake of the film speculation
continued to circulate but there wasn't
any new fuel to pour on the fire for a
couple of months
in a november 19 2016 interview with the
los angeles times johnson discussed his
initial post and his dynamic with diesel
when asked about the comments he'd made
johnson responded i've been in the game
a long time would universal pictures
have preferred that didn't happen sure
we talked about it the irony is after
that and as they do their tracking and
all their analysis the interest shot
through the roof to a whole other level
johnson's implication seemed to be that
whether or not it was the original
motivation for the post the publicity
generated by his online feuding only did
good things for the fate of the furious
to be fair the rock is a showman and he
came up through a wwe organization where
beefing was and still is a huge part of
publicity the actual tension between the
two stars likely still existed but it
seemed as though johnson was no longer
interested in fanning the flames i know
you guys are family
so i'm offering you a chance right now
to make that family whole again
on april 7th 2017 just days before the
fate of the furious was released
globally diesel resurrected the previous
year's feud in an interview with usa
today his words sounded kind-hearted at
first glance but they had a decidedly
backhanded quality to them he said i
don't think the world really realizes
how close we are in a weird way i know
he appreciates how much i work this
franchise in my house he's uncle dwayne
that's all pretty innocuous but diesel
quickly made it clear who he saw as the
true alpha in their relationship i
protect the franchise i protect
everybody including dwayne i protected
dwayne more than he'll ever know and
then he played the little brother card
dwayne has only got one vin in his life
dwayne johnson only has one big brother
in this film world and that's me while
it's true that diesel is a few years
older than johnson referring to the rock
as a little brother is in a word harsh
oh my my bad
i'm sorry i'm just processing
brother
though diesel claimed camaraderie with
johnson throughout the interview it
seemed clear what message he was sending
is only one king of fast and furious ask
any racer any real racer
it don't matter if you win by an inch or
a mile that's right winning's winning
finally after months of this back and
forth jabbing the fate of the fury is
premiered johnson and diesel both
appeared on the april 8 2017 red carpet
in new york city and they addressed
their beef in separate interviews with
e.t johnson said the disagreement had
simply been due to them having different
fundamental philosophies on how you do
things diesel in turn re-emphasized his
previous uncle dwayne remark in a
different universe that might have been
the end of it but just like how the fast
and furious franchise refuses to stop
pumping out bombastic films the feud
between diesel and the rock just
wouldn't go away it wasn't long before
the battle heated up again this time
with a third voice entering into the
arena this idea of family that is so
core with you that rules your world
it's a biological lie
on october 4th 2017 fast and furious
co-star tyrese gibson stepped into
diesel and johnson's feud after the
announcement that the release date for
f9 the fast saga had been significantly
delayed many presumed the delay was
mostly due to the impending spin-off
film fast and furious presents hobbs and
shaw starring johnson and jason statham
gibson appeared to believe the same
thing and he didn't hold back and
bashing the rock on instagram for quote
making the fast and the furious
franchise about you tyrese ended his
post by saying that he was quote just a
passionate film critic and going hard at
johnson by criticizing his turn in
2017's baywatch after so many months of
diesel and the rocks subtly going at
each other one-on-one tyrese's post
stirred things up majorly in the public
eye however rather than pylon johnson
diesel jumped in with what appeared to
be an attempt to squash the beef before
it heated up once again
two days after tyrese made his post
diesel took to instagram with an even
longer statement i know there has been a
lot of speculation as to why the fast 9
release date was pushed however like any
vehicle that has run around the globe
eight times the franchise is in need of
maintenance as a lead producer on the
franchise it makes sense that diesel
would want hobbs and shaw to find
success and his post seemed to show full
support for johnson's spin-off endeavor
for a while things seem to be at peace
once again
in a cover story interview with rolling
stone in april of 2018 johnson was once
again asked about the feud with diesel
specifically he was asked whether or not
the duo had actually shot any scenes
together for the fate of the furious
which was constructed in such a way that
the two never quite shared the screen
johnson confirmed this but he left his
reply simple and to the point
reiterating his past sentiments about
them simply having different
philosophies on things years later in an
october 2021 interview with vanity fair
johnson explained that not filming
scenes with diesel was one of his
conditions for returning to the
franchise i wanted to forgo drama i
thought that that was the best thing to
do for everybody that detail seems to
confirm that the tension between the two
must have preceded production on the
fate of the furious by a significant
amount of time
after the release of hobbs and shaw the
rock took to his instagram page to share
an especially sweaty celebration video
shot in what appears to be his gym
johnson thanked the cast crew and fans
for making the spin-off film a success
and declared how proud he was to be a
part of the fast and furious franchise
later in the video he made a cryptic
claim that of course all roads lead to
one thing
i'll be seeing you soon
johnson didn't appear at all in f9 the
fast saga which he claimed was due to
scheduling conflicts with hobbs and shaw
for nearly two years the beef lay
dormant but it apparently never got
squashed for good on june 22 2021 mins
health published a lengthy profile on
diesel where he once again discussed his
relationship with the rock he was a
tough character to embody the hobb's
character my approach at the time was a
lot of tough love to assist in getting
that performance where it needed to be i
would do anything i'd have to do in
order to get performances in anything
i'm producing diesel seemed to be
implying that his rocky relationship
with johnson was partially meant to
elicit a more compelling performance on
screen
the rock had one simple thing to say
about diesel's tough love comments in a
july 21 2021 piece from the hollywood
reporter i laughed and i laughed hard i
think everyone had a laugh at that and
i'll leave it at that sadly for fans
johnson also revealed in that same
interview that he has no plans of
returning to the franchise for fast and
furious 10 or fast and furious 11. i
wish them the best of luck on fast 10
and fast 11 and the rest of the fast and
furious movies they do that will be
without me after f9 the fast saga came
and went without even a mention of
hobbes many fans assumed that they'd
seen the last of johnson in the
franchise however that might not
actually be the end of hobbs if diesel
has anything to say about it
on november 7th 2021 diesel took to
instagram once more to ask johnson to
return to fast and furious after all
that had gone on between them the post
came as a shock to many but diesel was
clear about his desire to bring hobbs
back into the fold diesel wrote my
little brother dwayne the time has come
the world awaits the finale of fast 10.
after some elegant words about the
franchise's legacy and a promise he made
to paul walker diesel ends with a clear
call to action hobbs can't be played by
no other i hope that you rise to the
occasion and fulfill your destiny
obviously ahab's return in fast and
furious 10 would be great for the
overarching story of the franchise the
character has been a part of the series
most successful films and he's a clear
fan favorite plus now that john cena has
joined the series as dom toretto's
estranged brother jacob there's a chance
for the two former wwe superstars to
meet in one of history's biggest action
franchises that's an exciting
proposition but whether or not it will
happen is another question entirely
you're stronger together
you always were
as of the making of this video johnson
himself hasn't responded to diesel's
request for him to return however his
longtime business partner hiram garcia
has spoken publicly about the matter in
an interview with screenrant published
on november 14 2021 garcia said he
hadn't had much chance to speak with the
rock about the idea look dj is the
biggest movie star in the world no one's
below trying all attempts and approaches
to try and get him on board so i
appreciate it you got to take your shot
you never know though a bit con
descending in tone garcia isn't
necessarily wrong in his assessment of
the situation fast and furious was
certainly a huge launching platform for
johnson's international stardom but
since then he's worked on building his
own franchises like jungle cruise or red
notice getting him back on board with
diesel and the rest of the fast and
furious crew could be a complicated
process and that's assuming he even
wants to come back at all still there's
hope that fans could see dom and hobbs
side by side once again sometime down
the line after all fast and furious is
still a story about family and as we all
know you don't turn your back on family
even when they do
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast and the furious movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]